all right
- deep into this how many people in this
room are like ready for beer
so you will be pleased to know that the
only thing standing between you and beer
is me wait that didn't come out right
how many people in this room are kind of
tired like I've just had my brain turned
inside out several ways over and so I'm
going to come to a keynote and study
something really sort of light and
pleasant and not too complicated like
programming languages
right either but we'll go with it
one of the things from having done many
of these conferences over the years is
that what I've found is the people who
sit in those chairs frequently are
asking the same question right what is
the secret sauce what is the magic pill
what is the new framework what is the
hot platform what is the thing that I
need to know so that I can go back to
work and remain safely employed for the
next two years all right because that's
what we really want I mean you know all
of this you know giving back to the
community all of this you know trying to
improve follow our passions what I
really care about is not getting fired
right or getting outsourced or I I guess
if you're in if you're like in one of
those countries you traditionally
outsource to is it out outsource in
sourced sourced I don't know what is the
next big thing in our industry the
answer is programming languages thank
you for coming to my keynote enjoy your
beer fastest keynotes ever
but you're still not leaving so fine
let's talk about this there's a whole
bunch of different things that are
happening in the industry right now that
are sort of putting a lot of impetus and
emphasis around programming language
language research language ideas etc
what that means is in many cases
obviously we're going to be looking at
using a number of languages coming
you're coming down the pipe we already
of course use a fair number of
programming languages in our day to day
job as it stands but what I believe is
that we are actually going to start to
see an explosion a renaissance of
programming languages which we have seen
before we've seen many cases throughout
our history where people have
experimented with languages and then for
whatever reason that kind of opened up a
Pandora's box and suddenly everybody was
doing their own language but the other
thing that we are seeing is we're
exploring a lot of concepts within these
languages because quite frankly a very
important thing occurred a number of
years ago about five maybe ten years ago
we discovered that the world did not
stop with the invention of the
object-oriented programming language we
discovered that God does not think in
objects because what emerged quite
frankly was this huge interest in
functional programming languages which
solved a number of problems without
which object-oriented languages didn't
which of course leads all of the
functional programmers in the room to
nod and smile and say yes God thinks and
functions now he really doesn't he
really doesn't we stand on this
threshold oh yeah by the way who's not
interested in making money anybody in
here who's like complete socialist
No okay cool yes you know I kind of like
making money too we stand on this
threshold and part of what's happening
is we're actually closing a very very
important loop which up until this point
has been broken see historically the
programming language world has been
broken down into two very distinct and
very completely separate from one
another camps the first is the
practitioners I'm willing to bet most of
the people in this room are a part of
this camp the practitioner camp is the
camp of people who want to actually get
[ __ ] done if you are one of those give
me a raw
that was the lamest hoorah I have ever
heard have you never watched an American
War film brah about now seriously most
of the time when you go to a conference
like this the people in the audience are
people who are interested in getting
stuff done
they are often working for somebody else
working on somebody else's problems
working to create software that will not
be used by you and you get paid to do
that
and you get fired if you don't do that
right
I mean you are building something
typically for somebody else to consume
and you want to do a good job of it
don't get me wrong and you want to make
sure that the thing that you build is
something that people will say yeah this
is some pretty good stuff right you are
interested in meeting deadlines in
accomplishing features you are
interested in making sure that what you
deliver is in fact what was asked you
want to get this done quickly correctly
and frankly you just want to get it done
it's the practitioner camp on the other
side of that camp are the academics dawn
Syme are you in the room throw up your
hand if you are dawn is actually an
academic who is also a practitioner in
the sense that dawn currently works for
Microsoft Research steeps a lot of his
life in the academic world but he is
also a practitioner in the sense that he
is out there to create a programming
language that people will genuinely use
that is to say the f-sharp
programming language he's like the only
one
most of the time if you come to a
conference now be honest and you see
that a session is being given by dr.
so-and-so PhD computer science MIT how
many of you actually want to go to that
talk how many of you believe that going
to that talk will give you something
that you can actually use in the office
on Monday it might be a brilliant talk
it might be an amazing talk it might
explode your mind and make you think
about metadata in completely different
ways and then when you get back to the
office and you say and now I need to
move this button three pixels to the
left not sure how the academic relates
to my life which is very very odd
because in many other fields in most
other fields to be a academic to be
somebody who is dr. so-and-so that is
considered the pinnacle of success
within that career if we talk about
medicine the people who are in fact
running the hospital were frequently the
ones who are the best doctors if we talk
about lawyers law firms the people who
run the law firms they're the ones who
generally had the most success in court
the ones who didn't have success in
court we make them politicians
maybe that's just the u.s. I don't know
the academics are out there thinking
about things they are literally trying
new stuff new ideas new concepts new
what Evers and very bluntly they don't
generally worry about the things that we
the practitioner community worry about
they're interested in exploring a new
idea we're interested in shipping stuff
between these two groups lies a fairly
sizable gap and it does not help that in
many cases when we try to use some of
the academic stuff the academics when we
would go to them and say great this this
programming language you've created is
really really interesting how do I
access a relational database and the
academic would say who cares about
relational databases just store it in a
file how hard is that right there their
view their focus their perspective is
different from that of the practitioner
community if you say how do I take your
research language and run it in the
cloud they will say why would you want
to run it from 38,000 feet that doesn't
make any sense to me
you see that the the academic community
their focus is on getting that new idea
they're exploring this new space they're
playing around with this new idea and
they don't know if this is going to work
or not they're much more interested in
that feedback whereas we in the
practitioner community we can only use
their stuff if in fact their stuff can
do the various things we want it to do
it's not just about being a programming
language is not just about exploring a
new way of looking at the world
compositional inheritance instead of
traditional implementational heritance
that's great I love the idea about how
do I build a web server out of it
they're not interested in the things
that we are interested in and as a
result they don't spend as much time
focusing on the details for the real
world that we care about and
unfortunately what that does is it
breaks a feedback loop
and the feedback loop is the most
important thing that we can have in
computer science if you look at for
example the agile manifesto if you look
at all of the agile practices that we
see people doing today easily nine out
of ten are about feedback loop
unit tests making sure that if I change
the code that I get feedback immediately
to ensure that it didn't break the
on-site customer if I build something I
want my customer to be able to look at
it so that they can say yes this is what
I wanted or no this is not the whole
notion of story cards everything about
the agile manifesto is about feedback
because without feedback we can't know
if we're building something correctly or
not regardless of how fast we delivered
it regardless of how spiffy and what
features and how well it scales and so
forth if we don't get that feedback
we don't know if we're doing it at all
well it's no different the academic
world
historically what has happened is the
academics will go off and they'll do
their thing and the practitioners go off
and do their thing and maybe 20 years
later what the academics we're talking
about makes its way around to what we
deal with
this means that we don't get the benefit
of the ideas they are studying
and this means that they don't get the
benefit of our feedback around their
ideas and that means that programming
language research has generally been the
province of the academics alone and
unless you're one of those who is so so
so boring that you read academic papers
on a Friday night
instead of like actually going out and
drinking beer
you're not going to know about any of
this stuff you're not gonna have the
opportunity to take care of any of these
things and that's bad quite frankly I
mean if you want to really think about
this for a second
ocean of object-orientation
took about 20 years for it to really
sink into the mainstream small talk was
and one of the first if not the original
object-oriented programming language and
really it wasn't until twenty years
after its original introduction that the
notion of object orientation really
started to sink in into the mainstream
if you think about functional
programming some of the original report
around Haskell and its predecessor
Miranda that was all done basically in
the 80s and there was some refinements
that occurred after that dynamic
languages they were all the rage back in
the 60s Lisp in particular and then over
time we got to a point where we said
maybe we could play around with this
stuff Ruby JavaScript then came around
the second time because it was always
there in the browser but because it was
called JavaScript we thought it was
supposed to be like the programming
language Java which was the worst naming
convention ever because that also
suggests that ham should be similar to
hamster
it takes a really long time for these
ideas to eventually work their way out
of the academic community and into the
mainstream community until about let's
see what year is this 2019 until about
15 years ago there was a gentleman who
had spent a bunch of time in the
academic community and decided that he
wanted to experiment with sort of this
notion of how can we look at things
beyond objects and in particular what he
wanted to do is he wanted to examine a
concept called meta object programming
mo P and meta object programming is
something that's actually very
well-known in the Lisp community and he
wanted to actually take that and bring
it over into a mainstream environment
aka Java and so he worked on a language
that actually would let you do a
constrained subset of meta object
programming and he released this
language but contrary to what a lot of
the academics had done in the past he
built this language deliberately on top
of the Java Virtual Machine so it could
in fact interoperate with everything in
the java community
he called his language aspectj and he
called the style of programming that he
created aspect oriented programming
and if those of you have spent any time
in the Java space you know these terms
because they actually became the hot
thing to talk about in the mid 2000
because they captured this really nice
middle ground between where objects left
off and a lot of the distributed systems
containers EJB and so forth wanted to
pick up and the main reason that this
language got anywhere was because it was
a language that was developed on top of
the JVM so it could be introduced
directly into the mainstream right away
one of the things one of the tendencies
we are seeing today people are writing
languages that trans pile that is an
actual word that means we go from source
to source instead of source to binary
trans piling over into JavaScript and
the ultimate expression of that of
course is M scripting which for those of
you who haven't seen it in scripting is
a compiler that will take C++ and
compile it to JavaScript
because reasons
the best demo of in script in that was
out there for a long time I assume it's
still out there somebody actually took
the old quake source code
remember quake first-person-shooter run
around bouncing all over the map kind of
like you know overwatch but 20 years
earlier they took the quake source code
they compiled it with them script in and
you can run it in a web browser
so again if you're looking for things to
do while you know you're waiting for
Kevin Henny's deadlock tests to
eventually complete time dot eternity
you can actually go fire up a browser
fire up the quake code and when your
boss says what the hell are you doing
you say language research
I'm doing a performance test to see how
well natively compiled languages
transform into the browser at which
point your boss will probably just say
okay and wander back to his office which
is where he should have stayed in the
first place right by the way it's
Krypton is what later gave us wasum
which is webassembly which is what will
now run natively inside of most of the
modern browsers we'll talk a little bit
more about that in a second there's this
interesting perfect storm you guys
remember that move movie from about I
guess it was 10-15 years ago right
George Clooney and I forget who else
they're on a fishing boat
off of Boston several storms come
together to form a perfect storm right
the boat sinks George Clooney dies
everybody's happy
seriously George Clooney dies we're all
happy about that right no maybe just me
all right
there's this perfect storm of things
that are going on here step one
virtualization right we've seen some of
that already I'll talk a little bit more
about what that means we've got this
plethora of language tools that are
available to us there's this notion that
we actually do want to start thinking
more about languages which I'm just sort
of categorizing as linguistic focus and
we have this hype curve that we've now
sort of thankfully passed in the sense
of domain-specific languages the dsls
we're past the point of dsls being the
most amazing thing ever which means now
we can actually figure out how to use
them as opposed to them being alright
you know now that everybody is so amped
up around blockchain we can actually
start to think about how dsl should be
used that creates this perfect storm
center where we can actually do a whole
bunch of interesting language research
virtualization question how many people
in this room have had to worry within
the last year about memory like you had
to actually worry about deleting an
object
a couple of hands those are my C++
programmers right or I'm sorry rust rust
programmers is that the thing to join ow
right because worrying about memory was
was so much fun back in the 90s that we
have to bring that back if you program
in Java if you program in in dotnet
c-sharp vb.net f-sharp etc view program
in JavaScript right there is this
underlying machine that takes care of
all of these details did you have to
worry about how to export your class
name or function name so that it could
be loaded dynamically at runtime did you
have to worry about where your code
would reside did you have to worry about
how that code would be loaded see the
virtual machine was invented literally
to free you of all of these details to
not have to worry about whether or not
this pointer that you just received an a
method call is something that you own or
somebody else owns and are you
responsible for deleting it and if it's
an array do I have to use the special
bracketed form of delete or do I use the
standard form of delete what we
discovered with the rise of Java is that
love true love means never having to
call delete
we just let the system worry about that
now there are still some edge cases we
have to worry about database connections
may not necessarily get released as
early as we would like them to so we
have to put them in a special linguistic
block so they get on you know closed
earlier than when the object would be
reclaimed bla bla bla but for the most
part
being able to ignore some of the
physical details of memory management
freed up a whole slew of brain cycles to
focus on like actual problems
back in the day when I was doing C++
somebody several groups did some
interesting cognitive studies sort of
figuring out where you spend most of
your time thinking when you're sitting
down and writing code and all of them
came up to roughly the same conclusion
half of your day half of your day
programming I should say ignoring
meetings and whatnot was spent
specifically thinking about memory
management debugging problems when
you've got it wrong
debugging problems when you didn't get
it exactly right in other words you
forgot to delete something so you had a
memory leak that you had to close off
half of your programming day gone all
because some you have to think about
when do I allocate memory from where do
I allocate it how do I allocate it when
do I delete it at seven cetera the main
reason that Java took over the
enterprise space in the mid-to-late 90s
was not because Java was a superior
object-oriented programming language
quite frankly Java back in the day is a
crippled C++ it has nowhere near the
number of features that the C++ language
offers the one thing the JVM has to its
name basically is the fact that it
managed memory for you and a bunch of us
C++ developers went I like that and I'm
going to go do that and that's going to
make my life so much simpler and it did
that virtualization takes care of a lot
of those deep underlying details that
quite frankly if you're going to create
your own programming language you're
gonna have to figure out how exactly do
I store code where do I store it how
does it get loaded all of that is
handled for you by a virtual machine and
so if I target my new language to an
existing virtual machine I get to reap
the benefits of that VM and when Oracle
comes out with a new version of the VM
with a new garbage collector boom my new
custom language just gets better
but when I sit down to work on a
programming language like most
developers I want to have some good
tools that are available to me in order
to do that I don't want to have to write
everything by hand
the modern developer who wants to build
a web application when's the last time
any of you built your own web server
actually opening a socket and accepting
requests over port 80 parsing out
whether this was a get versus a head
versus a post yeah how many of you would
even know how to begin building a web
server
okay good you're not all hopeless that's
good
seriously most of that is just stuff we
take for granted here's a framework they
say you just provide some entries in us
construct that looks like this and
somehow magically when somebody issues a
web request against that server boom
your code will be invoked this is
amazing this is great you couldn't
figure out or build it yourself but why
would you having those tools having
those frameworks makes your life better
the language designers are in a similar
spot up until about 15 years ago the
only tools they had were Lex and yak
and I can tell who remembers those from
college because those are the ones that
are currently curled into a fetal ball
back there shivering I thought the
therapy had helped them apparently it
hasn't we are so far beyond those two
tools we have so many different tools
partial generators one of the better
ones that I like quite frankly is a tool
called antler it's an open-source parser
generator I can generate a variety of
different kinds of parsers it can give
you the syntax you know you can layout
and it actually has a debugger to go
with it because that's one of the hard
problems when you're trying to build a
language and you're trying to build out
syntax is trying to figure out whether
or not there is an accidental infinite
recursion somewhere inside your terminal
productions and so forth debugging
language syntax is actually a pain in
the ass and there have been a number of
frameworks and tools that have emerged
to actually make it easier to do things
like back-end code generation now again
if you're targeting the JVM in many
respects you can just target the JVM
here's a class file and off you go if
you're a developer you have Rosalyn
Rosalyn is literally a framework that
the Microsoft language designers build
to so that you can leverage it to parse
your code you can leverage it to
optimize your code to do some of the
various optimizations ast passes etc
that a modern language would do before
Rosalind there is actually the CCI the
compiler cassis ET compiler construction
toolkit which was sort of a predecessor
to Rosslyn it's still available it still
works
or there's mono Cecil or there's a
number of other dotnet specific assembly
specific tools
these are all tools that make it easier
for the prospective language designer to
get going get started there are example
grammars for almost all of these parser
generators for just about any of your
favorite languages so if you really
wanted to build a java script that
compiles to dotnet code to donna
bytecode I mean he actually wouldn't
take you a whole lot of work to do that
once you sort of reconciled Java scripts
weird sort of runtime object model to
how this would work inside of the net
world the language designers need those
tools every bit as much as you do and
they have a slew that are available to
them that weren't there two decades ago
the other thing that we are seeing now
is we're seeing emphasis on the idea of
maybe there is a world beyond objects
the functional programming community did
us all a huge favor in many respects
Gregor Cazalas started that when he
introduced a SPECT jet he started
talking about aspect oriented
programming and a lot of people started
to understand what he was talking about
but we've also seen the functional
community come around we've also seen
them talk about the benefits and the
potential drawbacks of using pure
functions versus impure mon ads and
monoids and category theory and year
whatever but one of the interesting
things that Paul Graham who has been a
big Lisp file for many many years he
will say that every so often the
language community discovers something
that Lisp had had from the beginning
they trotted out they ride it around and
everybody gets really excited and
meanwhile the people who'd been using
Lisp since the 70s disco and
there's a bunch of things that have been
introduced that Lisp didn't have Paul
Graham cites these nine things some of
these you will recognize a notation for
code using trees of symbols and
constants this is something we still
don't have in modern programming
languages directly although you could
argue that link and some of its runtime
expression generation is relatively
close to this but certainly when we
start talking about functional languages
currying the pure functions higher-order
functions have now made it in partial
application of functions we still don't
see that in a lot of mainstream
languages there's a lot of space in the
functional world that people are
exploring if you were in Kevin's talk
just a hour so ago you saw him do an
implementation of a stack that was
purely done with recursion using the
stack as a stack to a lot of people that
is a perfectly reasonable implementation
but would be very difficult to do in a
language like Java or C sharp because
the languages aren't really built around
that to do that in Haskell or to do that
in ml which is a purely functional
language much more approachable
we are talking about these ideas now we
want when you go to a conference in 2002
we're not talking about language
concepts we're not talking about
different ways to use recursion we are
talking about distributed systems and
that's it
servers and databases and application
servers and that is the principal focus
of that particular decade we are now at
a point where people are starting to
understand and talk more about these
language concepts and being willing and
interested in exploring more of these
concepts and that perspective is huge
because there's a whole bunch of things
that quite frankly we haven't solved if
you have been so fortunate or
unfortunate as the case may be to work
on a system that is a pure microservices
based architecture and you are building
a 12 factor application and you are
doing all of the things that that
application asks you to do terms of the
logging in terms of the management in
terms of the banking services and so
forth to go from zero to hello
production let me build a full fledged
production worthy micro service
application server lists or otherwise
that actually exports all the necessary
health checks has all of the necessary
administrative stuff ties in with all
the necessary authorization and
authentication tools the cognitive load
on the developer to deal with all of
that stuff above and beyond the domain
remember this is hello world but it's
all the stuff necessary to go to
production means that it's going to take
you months to get a Hello production
micro services app out the door
that's too much
world should be a couple of lines of
code and back in the 1990s 1990 let's
see 394 I think it was when we were
building 16-bit Windows programs using
the C programming language hello world
required by files
four pages of code
a deep understanding of how messages get
passed around inside of the Windows
operating system and then Team C++ and
C++ said let's take an object-oriented
viewpoint to this let's build a
framework that will hide a lot of this
common code and suddenly hello world
went from four files on a 17 page switch
statement down to one file five lines of
code ship
that's the kind of cognitive load that
you have to deal with and have to find a
way to get past because we've got write
the whole concurrency thing free lunch
anybody know what I'm referring to there
herb Sutter and his article the end of
the free lunch I don't know if you guys
have been paying attention to hardware
recently but you know Moore's law states
that every 18 months the number of
transistors that we can put into a
single square inch of silicon doubles
and usually this translates to we double
the amount of processor speed we double
the amount of memory we double the
amount of hard drive storage space
everything doubles about 18 months
and yet the fastest CPUs we have are
still measured in 4 gigahertz and last
year they were like 3.8 gigahertz and
the year before that they were 3.6 and
the year before that they were like 3.2
where exactly are all those transistors
going
well herb set her back in I think it was
2012 maybe even earlier than that maybe
her setter was noticing that we were
seeing a plateau in these processor
speeds and he wrote this now very famous
article called the the end of the free
lunch the era of the free lunch is over
in which he said basically what's
happening is we're not getting
processors that are faster we're getting
processors with more cores we have more
CPUs available to us when you buy a
graphics card today you are getting
basically a card with like thousand GPUs
on it because we can tackle those
transistors into creating all of these
separately independently parallel
processing graphics processing units and
it turns out that most graphics is very
very highly parallelizable
embarrassingly parallel is the term that
they like to use
so that means now as you start thinking
about your code you should be embracing
the idea of doing things in parallel and
everybody in this room is completely
comfortable with debugging highly
multi-threaded programs right show of
hands if you are totally comfortable
with debugging whatever parallel program
come on show of hands show of hands no
cuz let me be clear guys the processors
are not getting any faster so the era of
your code runs too slow you tell your
boss that you need about 18 months for
it to get about oh I don't know twice as
fast and then you play quake for 18
months and wait for the new generation
of CPUs to come out and then tell them
you need to do a hardware upgrade in
order to take advantage of all the
optimizations you put in the code that
that's done we don't get to do that
anymore if you are not taking advantage
of the parallelism that is implicit in
the CPUs that we are buying the code is
never going to get any faster
do we have a programming language that
deals well with concurrency we have a
number of languages that try to hide the
concurrency we have a number of
languages that try to create constructs
around the concurrency we have a number
of candidates who will tell you oh yeah
we've solved the concurrency problem and
they've solved some part of it
and then we have promises
and I mean that both literally and
figuratively in the JavaScript community
the answer to concurrency is promises or
we're gonna actually have a
multi-threaded JavaScript engine which
is really ironic because node was trying
to get away from multiple threads back
in the earliest days of nodes release
concurrency is still very much a
unsolved problem security
how many people in here feel absolutely
comfortable that your code is air tight
from a security perspective that there
is no possible way that anybody who does
not have the appropriate access token
will ever be able to see something they
should never see
it's really tired of racing your hands
or something very bashful all of a
sudden there's a whole slew of these
things that we need to solve and quite
frankly coming up with yet another user
interface framework for JavaScript for
putting up buttons in a DOM and
displaying it to people doesn't really
address any of these issues
we really need to move beyond
unfortunately there are a number of
folks who are really trying to move
beyond
within the last year I have become aware
of three programming languages the three
listed up there at the very top that are
advertising themselves as service
oriented programming languages the
matter-of-fact ballerina which is the
most fleshed out of the lot in terms of
in terms of its documentation and so
forth Jolie is actually an academic
effort so it's been around a little bit
longer but it hasn't been used much
Ballerina is done by the wso two guys
who have been big players in the web
services space for many many years but
ballerina specifically does not have
classes or objects I mean technically
they have objects they have instances of
a map type which behaves basically like
a dictionary and just about any other
language they have instances of a JSON
type they have instances of a set which
is what will allow you to be able to
consume stuff coming out of a relational
database but they don't have classes for
arbitrary objects instead you build
services with endpoints what would the
language look like the Ballerina
creators asked if you actually started
with the idea of a service as a first
class concept as opposed to something
that you stitch a bunch of objects
together to create
and that's a very reasonable question
bunch of folks that started
experimenting with for example aspect
oriented programming
Scala actually is a functional object
hybrid that has also spent a fair amount
of time exploring the idea of creating
internal dsls pizza was actually a very
early language that ran on top of the
JVM it was actually a predecessor to
Scala and the Java programming language
there is a language called e because I
think that was the only letter left
but E is actually exploring the notion
of capabilities-based security what
should various objects be allowed to do
what should their capabilities be when
you are talking about this particular
language and how will it work and so
forth in the Microsoft space of course
you've got Lync you've got F sharp there
are a number of languages that have
emerged out of the academic community
including them early or numeral
depending on who you ask
booooo was the language that was created
by Hyundai back before he got Ravin DB
off the ground and Bou was a language
which allowed you specifically to play
around with the ast at runtime very
Python inspired syntax but the idea is
that you could actually create
constructs and then during the
compilation phase get hooked into the
compiler and beyond be given an
opportunity to modify the code before it
was finished compilation and emitted a
tremendous amount of interesting ideas
and then outside of the two virtual
machine spaces Haskell Erlang which now
by the way has given us the elixir well
as well other things Haskell began Elm
which is a Haskell running inside of the
browser and elm ish I think Elm has been
renamed to L mesh and so forth there are
so many of these different languages
running around and if you really really
really want to start playing around with
some of the originals you really want to
explore some ideas that you haven't
really seen before fire up a small talk
browser golf and small talk or Pharaoh
or squeak any of those guys because one
of the interesting things that small
talk is small talk has been living this
virtual machine lifestyle for the better
part of half a century and they have
discovered some things you can do with a
virtual machine that those of us in the
Java and.net world hadn't even begun to
consider for example about let's see it
would be almost twenty years ago I was
working for the University of
california-davis
and their registration point-of-sale
system literally the application that
ran in the registrar's office when
students would come
to pay their reg fees it was written in
small talk and there was one guy Larry
was his name he's one guy who who had
been working on this point-of-sale
system since forever
I mean he was your classic bald with
white hair around the edges little
scatterbrained sometimes Larry was never
going to be fired
and he was very happy about that because
they let him play in small talk it was a
very very sort of parasitic really I
mean symbiotic relationship but one day
the the the Registrar's Office called
over and said hey there was a problem
there he said I'll be right there and he
promptly hung up and he got up and he
put his jacket on I'm like Larry what
are you doing he's like oh I have to go
over to the registrar's office they had
a problem with the point-of-sale system
I'm like oh yeah small talk you know it
sucks whatever go back to my Java then
he comes back and what he's got
basically is a floppy disk
neither floppy or USB key I can't even
remember now where we were in the cycle
but he's basically got portable media
with him and I'm like what's that it's
not like a dump of the log file he's
like no no no no this is the crashed
program
I'm sorry Larry what this is the crash
program here let me show you
he slides this thing into his machine he
brings it up what I discover in that day
is that small talk is not just a
language it's the browser it's the
environment the browser and the
environment are the IDE and so when
you're running this small talk
application in the browser not the web
browser but in the small talk browser
when an exception occurs the user has
the opportunity to hibernate literally
take the entire small talk browser
program and serialize it to disk error
state and all
copy that file off to a portable media
bring it back to his desk bring it up
and he is not looking at log files he is
not attempting to piece together a stack
trace he is looking at the actual
running program at the time the error
occurred
that's just [ __ ] cool and neither the
JVM nor the CLR have even begun to
embrace that although they very well
could there are still lessons to be
learned from the languages of our
ancestors and it's worthwhile to study
them
the other thing I will point out is even
if you have never built a programming
language anywhere in your history if you
were not a computer science student
which I was not my degree is actually in
international relations you really want
to have fun buy me a beer actually glass
of wine and ask me why war because that
was my final for one of my classes in
university I didn't study computer
science I studied international
relations foreign languages instead of
jet cetera and I have successfully
created programming languages once you
understand some basic concepts about
parsing the abstract syntax tree
transformation into either an
interpreted model or into byte code for
execution again there are frameworks and
tools to help you with this and you can
start relatively small and build your
own language in a day
and let me be very clear there is no
thing that a programmer can do that will
gather more respect from their
colleagues than create a programming
language if you say that you are working
on your own language and you show them
actual code in your language that you
can compile and run they are obligated
to let you have the first slice of pizza
because it means you understand a
subject that most people consider to be
deeply arcane and mysterious and the
doors are closed we'll let this be our
little secrets they're not actually that
hard it's really not that complicated
you can make it really complicated you
can make it really super complicated
come Scala
but it doesn't have to be
how real are these I mean to be fair
right
Ted you're up there on the stage they
asked you to do a keynote you're
supposed to sound inspiring I'm getting
kind of jazzed up but I can just see me
going back to the office and starting to
work on this and all of a sudden I lose
all that momentum because I realized
that yeah who's gonna really use this
and to be fair right
to be fair other people creating
languages generally don't have a
phenomenal amount of success for example
if you are a professor at a university
and you create a language the number of
people using your language directly
correlates to the number of undergrads
in your class that you can force to use
your language
right and maybe the TA and if it's a
successful research language it means
that you've convinced a couple of other
professors to do some research on your
language and they make all of their
undergrads use the language but
eventually you move on to something else
they move on to something else and the
language dies and this is the fate of
most programming languages in the
academic community if you're really
lucky your language will be used for ten
years within the academic space and then
it just dies now of course things to
github programming languages never
actually die they just live forever in
kind of a frozen state
and alike Captain America
some languages will cross this threshold
of immortality and will never die even
though they should I'm looking at you
pearl
I mean seriously the Perl community has
done everything they could to try to
kill it off and still it lingers
okay but all of that aside almost all of
the languages that we currently use
started life in research or academia C++
began life at Bell Labs when yarnís
Troost have decided he wanted to create
a language that was designed to pull
some ideas out of Simula and self and a
couple of other places to create a
object-oriented language a system-level
object-oriented language that was done
at Bell Labs many of the languages that
we use today as a matter of fact were
originally inspired by some of the work
done at Bell Labs small talk itself was
done at the Xerox Palo Alto Research
Center Xerox PARC Pascal see all of
these languages began life either in a
research institution or in academia the
only languages of note that were
actually created by the industry ADA
and COBOL
you want to volunteer for either of
those languages yeah so just because you
know people have created some of these
languages doesn't necessarily mean that
they're any better or worse in some
cases the right language just has to be
available at the right time remember
JavaScript was actually created in 1992
now a little bit later than that
basically around the same time that the
browser was first starting to gain some
traction and it's not until the last say
five or six years that JavaScript has
really taken off as a programming
language prior to this javascript was
just something you like you know view
source and stole from somebody else's
webpage pasted it on to your web page
and when it didn't work you said stupid
language and gave up right
but there's some interesting ideas that
were floating around out there so this
for example this is a flavor of
JavaScript that has since been basically
thrown away it was called efore X Eve
standing for xmas script because that is
the actual official name of what we all
call JavaScript the idea is that we were
going to integrate XML directly into the
language so that here var order order
was going to be a reference to an object
that was strictly hierarchical that
started with an order node which had a
child customer node and a child item
node and we could reference them by name
like so this was suggested back when we
were really thinking about web services
being XML based as opposed to JSON based
which is so much better and I say that
with a high degree of sarcasm
but just the idea of let's integrate xml
directly into the language it's not
actually a terrible one to start with
what are some of the things that we can
get out of it when we have a strictly
hierarchical representation particularly
because we can incorporate XPath which
was a query language for XML directly
into the language at that point which is
what e4x ended up doing
or let's take a completely different
view this inside the box is a
programming language called informed
seven
yes ladies and gentlemen that is a
programming language but is a
programming language for creating
interactive fiction
basically if you ever played adventure
games as a kid you were playing
interactive fiction
that's just cool I mean you look at that
and say to yourself could I present this
to the business analysts to my power
users to the people who understand them
could I give them something like this
and let them write the code directly
that's a pretty reasonable case you
could make them
we don't want to go quite so far with
quite such a strong English bench we
just want to incorporate certain kinds
of language concepts so here what we see
is an internal DSL from Scala in other
words this is actual Scala code here
anybody want to take a gander as to what
this actually does and if you say it
looks like it's querying from a
relational database right
this is the DSL for doing database query
so let's assume for the moment that
you're convinced let's assume that
you're like okay I got it
I get it I'm fired up I want to start
using some of these languages I want to
start playing around with some of these
languages I just have a big problem
how do I convince my management's that
this is actually a direction to go
because let's be clear management
actually has a legitimate concern that
if we start playing around with some
goofball academic language that is going
to die that quick death that we showed
earlier then where are we gonna find
people who are going to support it and
so forth and so on and you found a
language that isn't an academic language
that actually is available on github is
actually something that you would be
willing to support going forward etc
you've got all the technical concerns
handled but your boss still isn't
convinced how exactly do we do this
basically two paths right number one
assuming your boss is like much
management he strongly opinionated about
software and knows nothing about it
assuming your boss is like that it's
likely that the third path which is I'm
going to sit down have a reasonable
conversation and my boss is going to say
you know what this actually this bears
examination let's try a small prototype
and see where we get if you have one of
those bosses that's amazing and you are
to be congratulated for having found a
good place to work and please tell me
the name
nobody wants to shout it out alright
fair enough assuming you don't have one
of those bosses then you have two paths
available to you number one right just
overwhelming them with technical stuff
convince the boss this is the way we go
and start slowly or number two what your
boss doesn't know can't hurt them
and when your boss comes to you and says
hey Ted why is it that so many of our C
sharp files have a dot FS extension and
you say oh that's just the next
generation of c-sharp they didn't want
to confuse the extensions so they gave
it a separate one it's okay go back to
your office we got this
right cuz you know what goes in Vegas
what happens on the road
what
I can see that we have this transition
coming
cognitive load on the average developer
to build services to build micro
services right now is way too high
hundreds if not thousands of lines of
code to get one concept across and a
micro service driven application because
of all of these other concerns this is
the same place conceptually that we were
at when we were working with native
languages C and C++ and then we made
this transition to the virtual machine
which took so much of that load off and
we suddenly had this explosion this was
literally when the whole open-source
movement really got ramped up and
started there is a tremendous amount of
brain power that if we can free from
doing all of these low-level plumbing
tasks and make the plumbing live inside
the walls where we don't have to see it
except when we want to go tinker with it
then we can start being super productive
again as opposed to spending months
building a service that really in the
grand scheme of things doesn't seem to
accomplish all that much there are so
many areas that we can explore again if
you are in Kevin's talking here a few
minutes ago you saw him drawing out a
steep chart for the stack and showing
some of the interesting insights why
have we not incorporated the notion of
state transition and state transition
syntax directly into a programming
language instead we leave it up to you
the developer to manage all of that
stuff by hand there's a pattern the Gang
of Four described here's what the state
pattern would look like but nobody has
actually tried to incorporate that
directly into syntax or so many areas of
exploration and research that we can
dive into that for particular industries
that you might be involved in certain
areas will be far more interesting than
others don't wait for Don sign and
Anders hallsburg and Brian guts and all
of the other language design don't wait
for them to solve the problems because
they will solve the problems for
everybody
which means in many respects they're not
solving anybody's problems
your company your line of business your
industry has specific problems that are
unique to your space
start thinking about how would you solve
them differently if you had the syntax
to support it
spearmint with some syntax and build it
any questions
peace
[Applause]
you
[Applause]